E o que que é? Duas semanas,
pouco tempo, para criar qualquer coisa
por aqui
da dezembro. Então, esse ano
nós já temos final de outubro e nós
temos novembro, dezembro não conta.
Novembro eu vou estar super ocupado.
Aí vamos pensar. Eu tô pensando assim,
quando terminar o retiro lá do do
caminho do meio, eu tinha pensado ficar
no bacar, mas eu não sei, é um período
que eu acho que eu deveria retornar para
cá.
Deixa só por aqui. Talvez eu fique uns
dias lá e depois eu retorno até o
carnaval. Não vou a Floripa também.
Como?
Ah, eu acho que não.
Nós vamos ter um reto de Páscoa.
Eu fico aqui um pouco com Ten que eu não
tenho visto eles. Tô sempre.
ficar um pouco por aqui, mas aí eu acho
que eu vou oferecer um um estudo de
manhã, nesse período
janeiro né?
Aí em fevereiro aí é o retiro do Banco
Paris.
Depois começa
a
>> esse ano não sei, eu teria que olhar um
pouquinho. Eu acho que depois da minha
volta no dia 6, dia 6 14 acho que dá
para fazer alguma coisa, porque continua
logo depois, na semana seguinte, a gente
acho que dá.
Tá precisando de alguma coisa do super.
Pode contar, pode contar.
Talvez dê para fazer alguma coisa no
Curitiba nesses
porque assim é um dia assim e também os
dias sociedade a gente pode encaixar
cobram mais
>> aí seria o quê?
pedido de sociedade.
Eu sabe que o por exemplo as atividades
da da sangue el não me cansam.
Para mim é descanso, não é canal.
Será que ficou bom?
Qual atividade?
>> Pode ser domingo. Como como
pessoa achar, porque isso é Curitiba,
né?
Se for domingo para mim tá bem.
Eu
[Música]
gosto dos paranes que não sentem frio.
Isso eu acho bom.
E tu é paranaense mesmo?
Tu é do Paraná mesmo? É, é bom aqui
porque todo mundo vem um pouco de um
lugar do outro, né? Tem gente até da
Europa aqui.
>> É todo mundo um pouco infiltrado, né?
Mas eu acho que de todos aqui, o único
que tem um documento de cidadão do
Paraná mesmo sou eu.
[Música]
Budan
ganti.
Damar
[Música]
ganti.
Sangos.
গтими
[Música]
Paran
ganti.
Pangan
saran.
தூத
[Música]
சரனாமி
Paman
[Música]
saran
gami
tang
[Música]
saran
Ganvat
sambud
[Música]
sex
guru
[Música]
sex
Grup
hon rá
grup
de rom hon rá
hon romará
grup
hon romzará
grup de rom honra romzar
Grupo de romar
Grup
honrara
grupe de roman
romz
[Música]
Gurup
rom hon rar
grup
hon rar
Grup
honom
honra romar
grup
honra
Grup
[Música]
grara
gurzar
[Música]
grup.
Par
[Música]
sang
de s
[Música]
Para sanga
bandag
[Música]
Sangate
pandag
[Música]
parang
Bate
[Música]
para
tempar
Sтеaga
[Música]
tempar
Seng
[Música]
para
Senga
[Música]
paraga
tempanga
temande.
[Música]
Paraganga
de sraa.
[Música]
Par
tempar
[Música]
sangте
Paraga,
[Música]
temга.
Tempa
[Música]
tem
para sangте
[Música]
para
para sangar
[Música]
de sunga
até
paraga
[Música]
para sangar
tem
[Música]
sete
parag
[Música]
Sanga
tem.
[Música]
Então nós estamos no nosso estudo, a
gente tá chegando pra parte final, né?
Então a gente tá na parte do
renascimento, né? Bardo do viracer.
Então aí surge essa essa instrução, né?
Qualquer que seja a luz que brilhe
aí tudo aquilo que brilhar e a gente
tiver um impulso numa direção, a gente
podia pensar: "Não, eu vou cortar isso".
Não, a ideia não é cortar, a ideia é
iluminar isso. Como é que a gente
ilumina isso? a gente ilumina como o
senhor da grande compaixão. Então, do
mesmo modo que todos os sons, todas as
aparências, elas se tornam o mantra do
Senhor da Compaixão, também toda a luz,
tudo que brilhe, toda aparência de terra
e de referencial
que nos dê um suporte, nós olhamos isso
como um aspecto delusivo
que tá apontando diretamente para a
estrutura que tem nos aprisionado
durante muito tempo e que agora surge
como uma luz que de novo
começa a nos arrastar. E aí nós vemos
essa luz como brotando da natureza livre
da mente e se infiltrando por dentro do
das estruturas de karma e aparecendo
magicamente como uma bolha e nós como
uma identidade andando no meio daquilo.
Então a gente reconhece tudo isso como
se fosse apresentação direta e da
instrução de Cherenzig para nos libertar
daquilo que tem nos aprisionado por
vidas, né? Então, nesse sentido,
é que vem essa instrução, né? Ó filho de
nobre família, nessa hora o ponto
essencial da instrução é muito
importante. Qualquer que seja a luz que
brilhe, medite nela como sendo o Senhor
da grande compaixão.
Medite sobre o pensamento de que quando
a luz aparece, ela é o Senhor da grande
compaixão. Esse é o ponto essencial mais
profundo. Ele é extremamente importante
e evita o nascimento.
Medite por um longo tempo. Por que que
ele evita o nascimento? A gente não tá
se opondo. Por que que ele vai evitar?
Porque quando a gente consegue ver isso,
nós estamos na base da grande abertura.
E desse lugar não há nascimento. Desse
lugar só há lucidez.
Medite um longo tempo em qualquer que
seja a deidade que for seu idan, com
como sendo uma visão sem qualquer
natureza real intrínseca. Então o ida, a
deidade areatara, buda da medicina
é uma visão sem qualquer natureza real e
intrínseca como uma ilusão. Então uma
construção luminosa.
Isso é chamado de corpo ilusório puro.
A seguir, deixe que o Widan desapareça
gradualmente
na visualização das bordas até o
interior.
Reposeuse por um momento no estado
inconcebível
de vacuidade, luminosidade. Então o Iden
que nós estamos vendo, ele foi
desaparecendo e nós repousamos num
estado de vacuidade, luminosidade
que não consiste em absolutamente nada.
Aí medite novamente no seja faça o an
surgir e aí novamente
a luminosidade.
Medite alternadamente dessa forma e em
seguida deixe também que sua mente
desapareça.
Aí nós temos a a nossa própria mente que
é uma sensação
de existência de nós mesmos. Aí nós
vamos consumindo isso desde das bordas
até o interior.
Ah, isso desaparece. Aí novamente
a
fazemos surgir e cessamos.
Onde quer que haja espaço, a mente. Onde
quer que haja mente, ao dharmacaia
repouse no estado de simplicidade
e ausência de eu do dharmakia.
Estado de simplicidade e ausência de eu
do daria.
Pessoal, se o pessoal do Zem vê isso,
eles vão achar, viu? É o que eu sempre
disse.
Nesse estado, o nascimento é evitado e a
pessoa se tornará um Buda. O que que
significa o nascimento evitado?
Significa que a pessoa não vai tomar
originação dependente, vai ficar
construindo coisas e tomar uma
inteligência de base e fazer com que
coisas surjam e se sustentem, que enfim
será um mundo delusivo construído.
Mas aqueles cuja prática era fraca, aí
tem sempre humãs, né? Mas aqueles cuja
prática era fraca, que não eram aptos
meditação, não irão entender. E seguindo
confusos, vaguearão até a entrada do
útero.
O útero é a bolha. Por isso, as
instruções para se fechar a entrada do
útero são muito importantes.
Então, a pessoa vê as luzes como
tirenzig assim ela termina
vendo também todos os como delusivos. Aí
ela desaparece o id surgir, faz o an
desaparecer e surgir.
E aí ela faz a sua própria identidade
desaparecer, surgir, desaparecer. Ela
repousa nesse estado que é a vacuidade
de luminosidade.
É assim,
nesse estado o nascimento é evitado. A
pessoa se torna um Buda,
mas aqueles cuja prática era fraca e não
estavam, não eram aptos na meditação,
não fizeram os retiros, não fizeram os
estudos de aprofundamento, etc.
e seg e seguindo confusos, vagarão até a
entrada do útero.
Por isso, as instruções para se fechar a
entrada do útero são muito importantes.
Devemos chamar a pessoa pelo nome e
proferir as seguintes palavras:
seu trouxa. Quer dizer, ó filho de nobre
família, se você não reconheceu o que
aconteceu antes, porque você é um
trouxa, agora sentirá que está se
movendo para cima,
para baixo ou atravessando,
propelido pela força do karma. propelido
pela força do car assim, estou indo.
Portanto, nesse momento, medite sobre o
senhor da grande compaixão.
Lembre-se,
a seguir terá uma experiência como
aquela anteriormente descrita de
redimos, tempestades de neve,
tempestades de granizo, de ser envolto
pela escuridão e de ter inúmeras pessoas
o perseguindo e você fugirá. Então,
todos esses aspectos são as estruturas
cármicas que pertencem aos vários
reinos.
Aqueles desprovidos de mérito sentirão
que estão escapando em direção a um
local de sofrimento, mas os que possuem
mérito sentirão que estão chegando a um
local de felicidade.
Nesta hora, ó filho de nobre família,
todos os sinais da terra e do lugar onde
você nascerá aparecerão. Por quê? que a
pessoa já tá vendo a bolha,
a pessoa já tá nascendo.
Portanto, ouça sem distração, pois há
diversos pontos essenciais e muitos
muito profundos de instrução.
Embora não tenha entendido esses
segredos do reconhecimento antes, mesmo
alguém cuja prática era muito pobre
compreenderá este ponto aqui. Portanto,
ouça
nesse momento. É muito importante ser
extremamente cuidadoso com o método de
fechar a entrada do útero.
Então esse é o ponto, é é a parte final.
assim, se não deu isso aí não tem mais
solução.
Há dois métodos: interromper a pessoa
que está entrando e fechar a entrada do
útero que está sendo adentrado.
A seguinte é a instrução para
interromper a pessoa que está entrando.
filho de nobre qualidade,
visualize claramente a deidade que você
tem como Idan, como sendo uma visão
desprovida de uma natureza real
intrínseca, tal qual uma ilusão, ou a
lua na água. Seria assim, a lua no
espelho né?
Se não possuir um específico, ele é o
próprio senhor da grande compaixão.
Visualize-o nitidamente.
Ou seja, a ti de mil braços
aparecendo com muitos e muitos
diferentes meios na aparência que ele
surgir. Ele tá expressamente manifesto
[Música]
para nos
auxiliar, ultrapassar o karma que já tá
aparecendo.
Visualize o nitidamente.
Então aqui poderia ser a visualização
comum, mas pode ser também a própria
aparência que tá nos atraindo.
A seguir, deixe que o desapareça desde
as bordas até o interior
e medite sobre a luminosidade e
vacuidade
desprovida de qualquer objeto de
pensamento.
Esse é o segredo profundo.
E é dito que por meio disso o útero não
é adentrado. Portanto, medite deste
modo.
Mas se isso não o parar e você estiver
prestes a adentrar o útero,
existem instruções profundas para se
fechar a entrada do útero que está
prestes a ser adentrado.
Então, ouça, repita comigo essas
palavras dos versos principais do bardo.
Agora que o bardo do virá ser, então
esse último bardo, né, desponta sobre
mim. Como é que o bardo devera ser
desponta sobre a pessoa? A pessoa tem
boas ideias. Ah, vou fazer uma estupa,
uma coisa meu se eu fazer isso, vou
fazer aquilo, eu arrumar mais um
trabalho e vou fazer mais alguma coisa
assim. Então, agora que o bardo do
viacer desponta sobre mim, concentrarei
minha mente de modo unifocado
e me esforçarei para prolongar os
resultados do bom karma.
Fecharei a entrada do útero e pensa me
pensarei em resistência.
Nesse esse momento de perseverança
e pensamento puro,
abandone a inveja e medite no guru com
sua consorte.
Então, guru é a clareza da mente e a
consorte aparência que surge na conexão
com a aparência da mente.
Recite estas palavras de modo claro e
alto e desperte sua memória.
É muito importante meditar sobre o seu
significado e colocá-lo em prática.
Esse é o significado.
Agora que o bardo do vira desponta sobre
mim, significa que presentemente você
está vagueando no bardo do viracer.
Como sinais disso, se olhar para a água,
você não verá seu reflexo.
Que que significa isso? Se você olhar no
espelho, você não vê seu reflexo,
pá. Aí a coisa complicou total, né? Mas
o significado disso é assim. Se a gente
olha pro espelho, você não vê seu
reflexo. Por exemplo, nós olhamos aqui
em volta.
Todas as aparências. A gente não vê o
nosso reflexo, mas nós estamos criando
as aparências. A nossa cara tá naquilo
que é visto. Então a gente não vê. Isso
significa a gente não acessa a sabedoria
do espelho. A gente não vê. A gente vê
tudo separado e opaco como parece que é
que nós não temos o nosso rosto nas
coisas.
O seu corpo não possui uma sombra.
Uma vez que nesse momento não há um
corpo material de carne e osso, esses
são os sinais do corpo mental vagueando
no bardo do viracer.
Então, nós não vemos um, nós não vemos,
nós estamos olhando, a gente não vê o
sinal da nossa própria posição de mente.
Parece que tudo
tá ali, mas as coisas todas elas são as
sombras da posição da nossa mente.
uma vez que nesse momento não é um corpo
de material de carne e osso. Esses são
os sinais do corpo mental vagueando no
bardo do viráer.
Portanto, agora você deve concentrar sua
mente de modo unifocado e sem distração.
É agora que a concentração unifocada se
torna o ponto mais importante de todos.
É como usar as rédias para controlar um
cavalo.
Aquilo em que você se concentrar
se manifestará.
Por isso,
a sabedoria do espelho, né? O foco, eu
construo as bolhas e tudo se manifesta.
Por isso, não pense em ações negativas,
mas lembre-se do dharma, dos
ensinamentos, das transmissões
e das autorizações para textos, tais
quais essa liberação pela escuta que
você recebeu no mundo humano.
Esforce-se para prolongar os resultados
do bom karma. Isso é muito importante.
Não se esqueça, não se distraia.
Esse momento é a linha divisória que
separa a subida e a descida. Esse é o
momento em que se resvalar para a
preguiça, por um instante sequer,
você sofrerá para sempre. a preguiça que
seria o karma moa, né, que pertence ao
reino dos animais, que assim é uma
inércia, né, nós vamos seguindo como
for. Então isso é a preguiça.
Aí você sofreuá para sempre. Por quê?
Porque aí você entra na bolha calmamente
segue, que é o que tem sempre
acontecido.
Esse é o momento em que concentrando-se
de modo unifocado,
você será feliz para sempre. Por quê?
Porque nós vamos focando a mente, nós
terminamos descobrindo a realidade.
Concentre sua mente de modo unifocado.
Esforce-se para prolongar os resultados
do bom karma.
Aí vem os versos. Agora chegou a hora de
fechar a entrada do útero. É dito:
"Feche a entrada do útero e pensarei em
resistência".
Este momento pede perseverança e
pensamento puro.
Chegou a hora.
Primeiramente, a entrada do útero deve
ser fechada.
Há cinco métodos para fechá-la.
Entenda-os bem.
Ó filho de nobre família, neste momento,
projeções de homens e mulheres fazendo
amor aparecerão.
Quando as ver, não entre em meio deles,
que é como o guru e a consorte, nós nos
colocamos no meio.
Então, filho de nobre família, nesse
momento, projeções de homens e mulheres
fazendo amor aparecerão.
Quando as ver, não entre no meio deles,
mas recorde-se e medite sobre o homem e
a molhar como sendo guru e sua consorte.
Então é como sendo a mente que se move e
o mundo como é visto.
Mesmo que a pessoa esteja vendo homens e
mulheres, ela adivinha que ali tem um
uma inteligência.
E tem um mundo como é visto de lado a
lado.
Mentalmente
prostra-se e faça oferendas com profunda
devoção
e solicite os ensinamentos.
Assim que você se concentrar
intensamente neste pensamento, a entrada
do útero certamente será fechada.
Mas se isso não a fechar
e você estiver quase adentrando o útero,
medite sobre o guru e só consorte na
forma de seu próprio
por quê? Porque se a pessoa ela tiver
olhando de modo
condicionado,
portanto, a pessoa tiver quase
adentrando aquele mundo mental,
reconheça então que o guru e a consorte,
por aparecerem de forma muito intensa e
mobilizadora,
elas são o próprio a própria estrutura
cármica se manifestando de modo
compassivo nesse momento para que a
gente entenda aquilo e repouse na grande
abertura em meio a essa visão.
Isso significa reconhecer o guru e a
consorte na forma do próprio ou do
senhor da grande compaixão com sua
consorte
e mentalmente faça oferendas. Então, as
oferendas não é oferenda de flor, de
água, oferenda de lucidez.
Aí veja, uau. Aí siga fazendo oferendas.
Quantas oferendas são feitas, as nuvens
de oferendas são feitas, elas não podem
ser feitas senão
desde a natureza da grande abertura, que
é a natureza lúcida.
Se nós estamos na grande abertura
fazendo oferendas, nós fechamos a
entrada do útero. Simplesmente isso é
fechar a entrada do útero com intensa
devoção. Peça a eles que confiram
realizações espirituais. Então nós
olhamos essas imagens e conhecemos como
uma inteligência búdica, lúcida,
apresentando
os obstáculos na forma de de bênçãos que
nos vão levar além do sansar inteiro.
Então nós olhamos desse modo. Então isso
é fazer as oferendas e ao mesmo tempo,
na medida em que a gente passa a
reconhecer um pouco isso pelas próprias
oferendas, a gente pede que as
realizações espirituais correspondentes
surjam.
Então nós estamos um pouco lúcidos e um
pouco não lúcidos. Por isso que a gente
pede as realizações espirituais.
E isso na medida em que nós estamos
praticando desde a grande abertura,
fecha a entrada do útero.
É assim. Aí não há como entrar.
Isso é como, por exemplo, o Buda
dizendo,
o corpo ele é constituído de ossos,
unhas e cabelos, etc. Aí tu
quebra aquela aquele aspecto delusivo
todo né?
Aí vem assim: "Mas se isso não fechar e
você estiver quase adentrando o útero,
essa agora é a terceira instrução sobre
como abandonar a paixão e a agressão.
Desejo apego e agressão. Então dos três
venenos, nós temos dois.
Há quatro tipos de nascimento. Aí começa
assim, né? Começa os nascimentos,
os tipos de nascimento.
O nascimento a partir de um ovo, o
nascimento a partir de um útero, o
nascimento espontâneo e o nascimento a
partir da humidade.
Estes são similares o nascimento a
partir de um ovo e a partir de um útero.
Até mesmo porque o nascimento a partir
de um útero é o nascimento a partir de
um ovo que tá escondido dentro de um
útero. Então é similar.
Como acima haverá projeções de machos e
fêmeas em união sexual.
E se nessa hora você adentrar um útero
propelido pelo poder da paixão e da
agressão,
nascerá como um cavalo,
um pássaro, um cachorro, um ser humano e
assim por diante.
quer que seja.
Se estiver
a caminho de nascer como um macho, você
terá a experiência de si mesmo como um
macho e sentirá uma violenta agressão
pelo
pai que seria então naquele casal ou
macho. Bem como ciúme e desejo pela mãe.
e estiver a caminho de nascer.
Então aqui essa componente ela se
preserva. Então os homens que nascem
como homens terão agressões pelos homens
e eles terão e desejo pelas mulheres.
Se estiver a caminho de nascer como uma
fêmea de qualquer uma dessas categorias,
né? Você terá a experiência de si mesmo
como uma fêmea e sentirá intensa inveja
ciúme da mãe que segue então durante a
vida como ciúme inveja das outras
mulheres,
bem como intenso desejo paixão pelo pai
que segue com essa conexão.
Isso o fará ingressar no caminho que o
conduz ao útero. Então, no momento que
isso tiver operando, isso surge como se
fosse uma realidade que induz o
movimento. Aí a pessoa já tá no útero
e o só fará ingressar no caminho que
conduz ao útero e você experienciará a
bem-aventurança
autoexistente
em meio ao encontro do esperma com o
óvalo.
Então, quando isso ocorre como essa
tendência clara do movimento, quando o
movimento se
se produz,
quando o movimento se produz, a pessoa
tem uma sensação de bem-aventurança,
porque aquilo andou na direção que ela
aspirava.
E e você experienciará a bemaventura,
bem-aventurança
autoexistente
em meio ao encontro do esperma com o
óvulo.
Nesse estado de êxtase, você perderá a
consciência.
Ora o embrião crescerá redondo e o oval
e assim por diante, até o corpo
amadurecer e deixar o útero da mãe.
Você abrirá os olhos e terá se
transformado em um filhote de cachorro.
Não sei o qu, né?
Antes um homem, agora você se
transformou em um cachorro e assim
sofrerá em um canil
ou de modo seelente um chiqueiro, um
formigueiro, um buraco de minhoca, ou
então nascerá como um bezerro, um
cabrito, um cordeiro e assim por diante.
Aqui já não há retorno.
Por quê? Porque a pessoa agora ela tá, a
mente dela tá se manifestando de acordo
com as condições que já estão
estabelecidas. Você passará por todo
tipo de sofrimento em um estado de
grande estupidez e ignorância. Por que
estupidez e ignorância? Pensa: "Não, mas
os bichos são espertos. Não, estupidez e
ignorância. Por quê? Estupidez porque a
pessoa não pensa que a mente pode ir em
qualquer outra direção a não ser seguir
aquilo." E a ignorância é o fato de que
a pessoa não tenha menor compreensão da
não dualidade, nada.
Eh, é o, é uma mente operando segundo
as suas atribuições cármicas,
gerando desse modo pelos seis reinos da
existência,
o dos seres dos infernos, dos fantasmas
famintos e assim por diante, você será
atormentado por um sofrimento sem fim.
Por que que vai gerar? Porque tem a
morte depois renascimento e morte
renascimento, mas tem sempre uma
sensação de alguém fazendo alguma coisa.
É esse alguém fazendo alguma coisa que
passa pelas múltiplas fases da vida e as
múltiplas vidas em sucessão.
Não há nada mais poderoso ou assustador
do que isso. Que tristeza. Que tristeza.
Aqueles que não possuem os ensinamentos
sagrados de um guru cairão no grande
precipício do sansara e passarão por
sofrimentos ilimitados e insuportáveis.
Eles são ilimitados e insuportáveis, mas
a pessoa não morre no meio dos infernos.
Importante entender isso. Portanto, ouça
as minhas palavras e compreenda esta
instrução.
Agora foi dada a instrução de como
fechar a entrada do útero pelo abandono
da paixão e da agressão.
Agora compreenda, é dito. Feche a
entrada do útero e pense em resistência.
Este momento pede perseverança e
pensamento puro. Abandone a inveja.
Medite no guru com sua consorte.
Como acima você terá sentimentos de
inveja. Se estiver a caminho de nascer
como um macho, você amará a mãe e odiará
o pai. Se estiver a caminho de nascer
como uma fêmea, você amará o pai e
odiará a mãe. Portanto, neste momento,
há uma instrução profunda.
Ó filho de nobre família, quando a
paixão e agressão surgirem assim, medite
da seguinte maneira.
Que tristeza.
Sou um ser com um karma tão negativo que
venho que tenho vagueado pelo sansar até
o presente de devida fixação na paixão e
na agressão.
Se eu continuar seguindo paixão e
agressão desse modo, vagiarei
eternamente pelo sansara e afundarei nas
profundezas do oceano do sofrimento por
um longo tempo.
Por isso, agora não sentirei nem paixão,
nem agressão.
Que tristeza. De agora em diante, nunca
mais sentirei paixão e agressão.
Os tantras dizem que se você concentrar
sua mente intensa e unifocadamente nesse
pensamento,
isso por si só fechará a entrada do
útero.
Pessoal, o sentido sutil disso é assim.
Nós repousamos na grande abertura,
portanto, nós nós iluminamos a paixão e
agressão.
Se a gente interpretar isso como uma
luta contra paixão e agressão, a gente
não tem vitória, porque a mente,
a mente lutando contra a mente, ela
empata,
mas a natureza livre da mente, ela é
maior do que qualquer estado mental.
Ó filho de nobre família, não se
distraia, concentre sua mente de modo
unifocado.
Se mesmo depois disso a entrada do útero
não for fechada e você estiver se
encaminhando para adentrá-lo,
então ela deve ser fechada por meio da
instrução sobre a natureza irreal e
ilusória de todas as coisas.
Menti-se dessa maneira.
Que tristeza, que tristeza é assim, tô
tonto.
Pai, o pai e a mãe, a grande tempestade,
o furacão, o trovão, as projeções
assustadoras e todos os fenômenos
aparentes são por natureza ilusórios,
independentemente de como aparecem, não
são reais.
Todas as substâncias
e os elementos,
terra, água, fogo, ar, são falsas e não
verdadeiras.
São como uma miragem,
não são permanentes,
não são imutáveis.
Então aqui, pessoal,
para viver isso, a pessoa repous sobre a
grande abertura. Então, é como se ela
tivesse diante da assembleia. Então,
todas as manifestações que brotam de
todos os mundos e todos os seres se
movendo daquele modo, tudo isso é
dilusivo e ao mesmo tempo lo, mas ao
mesmo tempo vazio.
Não há uma prisão verdadeira.
Então, por isso nós vemos o pai e a mãe.
Aí nós nos mantemos na grande abertura.
A gente vê eles operando de modo
condicionado.
A grande tempestade, a grande tempestade
não atinge aquilo que não é construído.
O furacão, o trovão, nada disso atinge a
natureza que não é construída. As
projeções assustadoras, aí nós
simplesmente repousamos na grande
abertura.
E todos esses fenômenos aparentes são
por naturezas ilusórios, independente de
como aparece, não são reais.
Todas as substâncias, ou seja, tudo que
parece que a terra, que é referencial,
são falsas e não verdadeiras. São como
uma miragem, não são permanentes, não
são imutáveis.
Para que serve o desejo? Para que serve
o medo?
Isso é considerar que o não existente
se torna existente, ou seja, se a
própria a natureza da originação
dependente né?
Tudo isso são projeções da minha mente e
visto que a mente é ilusória,
né? Então essas disposições mentais,
elas também são ilusórias, elas não têm
uma existência própria.
A partir de onde externamente ela surgem
desse modo, elas surgem quando as
aparências surgem no mesmo instante, né?
Eu não compreendi isso antes. Então
acreditei que o não existente existia e
que o verdadeiro, que o não verdadeiro
era verdadeiro e o que ilusório era
real.
Consequentemente tenho vagueado no
sansara por um longo tempo. Se eu não
perceber que isso são isso tudo são
ilusões, seguirei vagueando no sansara
por muito tempo ainda e com certeza
sucumbirei ao pântano lamacento do
sofrimento.
Agora, tudo isso são como sonhos, como
ilusões,
como ecos. Então, tô na grande abertura,
eu vejo tudo como uau, surgimentos
luminosos sonhos ilusões ecos como
cidades de Gandarvas,
que são cidades dos músicos que produzem
sons variados,
como miragens, como imagens, como
ilusões óticas, como a lua na água.
Não são reais, nem sequer por um
instante. Certamente não são
verdadeiras,
mas são falsas. Fals significa não dais,
luminosas, vazias, como a gente já
estudou né?
Concentrando-se unificadamente nesta
convicção
e crença na realidade das aparências,
desculpa, concentrando-se unifocadamente
nessa convicção, a crença
delusiva na realidade das aparências é
destruída.
E quando nos e quando nos convencemos
internamente desse modo, a crença no eu
é ultrapassada.
Se compreender a não realidade
dessa forma,
do fundo do coração, a entrada do útero
com certeza será fechada.
Mas se mesmo depois de fazer isso, a
crença na realidade não for destruída
e a entrada do útero não for fechada e
se foi se estiver se encaminhando para
adentrá-lo,
há uma instrução profunda. Então, mais
uma.
ao filho de nobre família, se mesmo de
depois de fazer tudo isso, a entrada do
útero não for fechada,
agora ela deve ser fechada por meio do
quinto método, a meditação sobre a
luminosidade,
que deve ser feito do seguinte modo:
as substâncias,
ou seja, os elementos são minha própria
mente.
E essa mente é a grande abertura, ou
seja, a vacuidade
não surgida e desobstruída.
Pensando assim, mantenha a sua mente
natural e não diluída,
autocontida em sua própria natureza.
Ou seja, repouse sobre esse estado de
grande abertura,
como água derramada sobre a água tal
qual é.
solta, aberta e relaxada.
Ao deixá-la repousar naturalmente,
relaxadamente,
grande abertura, você pode ter certeza
de que a entrada do útero, de todos os
quatro tipos de nascimento, certamente
será fechada,
porque nós vamos olhar as aparências e
vamos reconhecer que elas são o que são,
porque nós estamos na grande abertura.
Diversas instruções verdadeiras e
profundas para fechar a entrada do outro
já foram oferecidas.
Impossível que alguém de capacidades
superiores, medianas ou inferiores, quem
quer que seja, não seja liberado através
delas. E por quê?
Primeiramente, porque a consciência no
estado do Bardo possui uma percepção
sobrenatural das coisas mundanas e é
capaz de ouvir o que eu digo. Em segundo
lugar, mesmo que a pessoa tenha sido
surda e cega, agora todos seus sentidos
estão completos e, portanto, ela
consegue escutar o que é dito, porque o
que tá sendo dito é a própria visão da
mente. A mente não precisa de som.
Terceiro lugar, por estar o tempo
inteiro dominada pelo medo, ela está
pensando sem distração sobre o que fazer
e consequentemente está ouvindo o que
estou dizendo.
Em quarto lugar, como a consciência não
possui qualquer apoio,
ela se encaminha diretamente para onde
quer que a concentração se dirija. Por
isso, é fácil guiá-la. A mente está nove
nove vezes mais clara.
Assim, mesmo que a pessoa seja
ignorante, devido à força do karma, a
mente se torna tão clara nessa hora que
a pessoa é capaz de meditar sobre o que
quer que seja ensinado.
Pontos essenciais como esse são
são a razão.
Por esses mesmos motivos, também é
benéfico realizar rituais para os
mortos.
Portanto, é muito importante perseverar
na leitura desta grande liberação pela
escuta até nove vezes.
Mesmo que não se libere em uma das
demonstrações,
a pessoa se liberará na seguinte. É por
isso que não apenas uma, mas diversas
demonstrações são necessárias.
Contudo.
Aí tem o Contudo. Aí aquilo
inevitavelmente atinge o resultado.
Contudo. Mesmo assim a incontáveis
pessoas que não tinham o costume de
fazer boas ações,
ao mesmo tempo que eram muito
habilidosas nas ações negativas,
devido à influência de diversos e
poderosos véus do engano.
Então, não são liberadas, apesar de
terem sido apresentadas e recebidas e
recebido esses objetos de meditação por
tantas vezes anteriormente,
né, elas não conseguiram. Portanto,
agora se a entrada do útero ainda não
foi fechada, uma instrução profunda
sobre como escolher a entrada do útero
será oferecida a seguir, ou seja, comer
para um lugar melhor, já que vai entrar
no outro.
Devemos chamar pela ajuda dos budas e
dos bodissáas e repetir o refúgio.
Então, chamar a pessoa morta pelo nome
três vezes e recitar essas palavras.
Ó filho de nobre família
que está morto, escute.
Embora você tenha recebido a
demonstração por meio dessas instruções,
tantas vezes você não compreendeu.
Por isso, agora se a entrada do útero
não foi fechada, chegou a hora de
assumir um corpo.
Não há apenas uma, mas numerosas
instruções profundas e verdadeiras sobre
como escolher a entrada do útero.
Portanto, compreenda sem distração,
ouça bem, concentre-se intensamente e
entenda.
Ó filho de nobre família, nesse momento,
os sinais e características do
continente
onde você nascerá aparecerão.
Seria como o mundo onde você vai
surgir aparecerão.
Portanto reconheça-os
examine o local onde está prestes a
nascer e escolha o continente.
Caso esteja se encaminhando para nascer
o continente a leste,
nobre corpo,
você verá um lago ornamentado com
gansos.
Pense na resistência e não vá para lá.
Embora seja pleno de felicidade, é um
local onde o dharma não floresce,
portanto não o adentre.
Caso você esteja se encaminhando para
nascer no continente do sul, a ilha do
Jambo Rosa,
então o Monte Meruz, quatro continentes,
continentes menores, Plandor, a glória
dos Deus, humanas. Então aqui, caso
esteja se encaminhando para nascer no
continente do sul, a ilha do Jambo Rosa,
você verá moradas belas e luxuosas.
Se deve adentrá-la se conseguir.
Caso esteja
se encaminhando para nascer no
continente do oeste de leite das vacas
que realizam desejos,
você verá um lago ornamentado com
cavalos e é. Não vá para lá. Volte.
Embora ofereça muitos prazeres, esse é
um local onde o darva não floresce.
Portanto, não o adentre.
Caso esteja se encaminhando para nascer
no continente do norte, som
desagradável,
você verá um lago ornamentado com gado
ou árvores. Reconheça-os como sinal,
sinais de tomada de nascimento.
Porque quando a pessoa vê o mundo, ela
já tá com a mente daquele mundo.
Mas ainda assim reconheça-os como sinais
de tomada de nascimento e não entre lá.
Embora ofereça uma longa vida e mês, o
dharma não floresce neste local,
portanto não o adentre.
Caso esteja se encaminhando para nascer
no mundo dos deuses, você verá lindos
templos de muitos andares feitos de uma
infinidade de joias.
Se estiver apto a entrar aqui, você deve
fazê-lo.
Caso esteja se encaminhando para nascer
como um Deus invejoso,
você verá belos bosques,
ou então o que parecem ser rodas de fogo
girando.
Não entre aqui de modo algum. Pense na
resistência.
Caso esteja encaminhando para nascer
como animal, você verá como que
ofuscadas por uma névoa cavernas de
pedra e buracos no chão e cabanas de
palha
não entre aqui.
Cas esteja se encaminhando para nascer
como um fantasma faminto, você verá
troncos de árvore
e formas escuras cravadas no solo,
cavernas ou manchas negras. Se seguir
nessa direção, você nascerá como um
fantasma faminto e experienciará todo
tipo de sofrimento decorrente da fome,
da sede. Por isso, não adentre esse
local de modo algum. Pense na
resistência e mantenha uma forte
perseverança.
Caso esteja se aproximando para nascer
como um ser dos infernos,
você ouvirá músicas cantadas por aqueles
de karma negativo.
Ou terá de adentrar sem poder fazer nada
para evitar,
ou sentirá que chegou em uma terra
escura com casas vermelhas e pretas,
covas e entradas escuras.
Se seguir nessa direção, você adentrará
o inferno,
experienciará um sofrimento
insuportável.
decorrente do calor e do frio, do qual
nunca conseguirá escapar.
Portanto, não vá para lá. Não adentre
esse local de modo algum, mas tenha
cuidado.
É dito, feche a entrada do útero e pense
na resistência.
Isso é muito necessário. Agora,
ó filho de nobre família, ainda que
deseje não se seguir em frente, você não
tem nenhum poder. Por quê? Porque a
pessoa já passou por todas as regiões
essas que ela poderia ter tido o poder.
Agora está sendo desamparadamente
propelido nessa direção.
Atrás de você, os vingadores do karmo
perseguem. À sua frente, os vingadores e
assassinos o arrastam pelo caminho. Por
que isso? Porque essencialmente o que tá
impulsionando a mente da pessoa são as
visões cármicas.
E atrás
também é o karma que surge como todas as
aparências.
Assim escuridão furacões tempestades
violentas, barulhos, neve e chuva, e
tempestades ferozes de granizo e de neve
rodopiarão à sua volta e você fugirá.
Ao fugir, procurará um refúgio
e encontrará segurança nas casas
luxuosas descritas anteriormente,
ou em abrigos de pedra e buracos no
solo, entre árvores e nas cavidades
redondas das flores de lotos e assim por
diante.
Escondido lá, terá medo de sair e
pensará: "Não posso sair daqui". E
devido ao medo de sair, você
desenvolverá apego a tais locais. Você
terá medo de se defrontar com os
terrores do bardo caso saia.
estará profundamente assustado e, por
isso, se esconderá
nesses lugares e e acabará por assumir
um corpo ainda que muito ruim, o que
resultará em todo tipo de sofrimento.
Isso é um sinal de que os demônios e
forças malévolas
estão obstruindo-o neste momento. Logo
há uma instrução profunda para essa
hora.
Ouça e compreenda.
Nessa hora de terror em que está sendo
perseguido pelos Vingadores,
você deve visualizar imediatamente com
sua mente plenamente presente o supremo
abençoado Eu ou Raia Griva ou Vajapani
ou seu Widan, caso você tenha um.
Visualize ele como possuindo um enorme
corpo e membros volumosos
com uma atitude assustadora de ira que
destrói todas as forças do mal.
Separados dos Vingadores por suas
bênçãos e compaixão,
você terá o poder de escolher a entrada
de um útero. Esse é o segredo profundo
da instrução.
Portanto, compreenda. Então, se a pessoa
tiver essa conexão cármica, ou seja, ela
não conseguiu lidar direito com as
deidades e reconhecer como vazias.
Mas ela acredita então na existência das
suas deidades. Então ela ela evoca o
supremo abençoado Eu Buda.
O Buda assustador que derruba tudo, que
destrói tudo.
Então, mesmo que haja coisas muito
assustadoras e perturbadoras, cármicas,
que a pessoa sinta, ela evoca alguma
coisa muito maior que destrói aquilo
tudo.
ou Raiava ou Vajapan, ou seua, caso você
tenha um com possuindo enorme corpo e
membros volumosos, com uma atitude
assustadora de ira, que destrói todas as
forças do mal.
Separado dos dos vingadores por suas
bênçãos e compaixão, você terá o poder
de escolher a entrada de um útero. Esse
é o segredo profundo da instrução.
Portanto, compreenda. Nós estamos
tomando o aspecto grosseiro das
aparênças das deidades.
Ó filho de nobre família, os deuses da
meditação e assim por diante nascerão
pelo poder do samad.
Uma grande classe. Então, os deuses da
meditação, que é os deuses da eh da
forma e da não forma.
nascerão pelo poder do que da prática de
meditação.
Eles são autosurgidos, eles nascem por
si mesmos. Uma grande classe de
espíritos malévolos como fantasmas,
famintos e assim por diante mudaram sua
atitude enquanto estavam no estado do
Bardo e, por isso são capazes de
aparecerem diversas formas ilusórias de
fantasmas famintos e demônios,
transformando-se nesse corpo mental.
Os fantasmas famintos que residem nas
profundezas do oceano
e os fantasmas famintos que voam pelo
espaço
e todas as 80.000 Classes, de forças
negativas e assim por diante, assumiram
aquele corpo mental ao mudar
sua atitude.
Nessa hora, a melhor coisa
a melhor coisa. Então, por que que esses
todas essas forças negativas surgem como
eh deuses que brotam do poder do Samad,
né?
Porque em todos esses casos, incluindo
os deuses da forma e da não forma, nós
temos uma aspiração, nós queremos obter
alguma coisa. Então, é como se houvessem
ainda fantasmas famos enquanto
o aspecto sutil da própria meditação.
Portanto, nessa hora que nós estamos
fixados a objetivos
dentro do mundo da forma, da não forma,
a melhor coisa é contemplar o grande
símbolo da vacuidade, ou seja, a natural
perfeição, a natural abertura diante de
todos os estados mentais. E aí, nesse
momento, os estados mentais de
meditação, eles ficam vistos como tal,
ou seja, eles são estados de pobreza
e de fixação.
Então, isso é marramudra,
o grande símbolo.
Mas se não conseguir fazer isso,
participe do jogo da ilusão. Ou seja, aí
você tá vendo as coisas
que é o próprio Samad.
Se não for capaz de fazer isso
também, então pelo menos não tem nenhum
apego a nada
que você esteja
em nenhum samade também e medite sobre o
seu
então de novo, a gente olha o karma, o
karma surge como mo Então nós
naturalmente vemos o nosso karma
surgindo como o
senhor da grande compaixão. Então, as
aparências do Idan, elas são as
aparências que lucid o nosso próprio
karma. Então, isso é a manifestação do
Senhor da grande compaixão.
E você se tornará um budoakia no estado
do Bardo. Pessoal, isso é uma repescagem
inacreditável.
Mas é isso,
né? Gru em Poch não desiste. Ele não
desiste. Nós já estamos lá perdidos
total. Ele dá uma puxada e nós viramos
Buda no Sambo Gakai.
Ó filho de nobre família,
se tiver que adentrar um útero movido
pela força do karma, a instrução de como
escolher a entrada do útero será agora
ensinada.
Ouça, não entre simplesmente em qualquer
entrada de outro que aparecer.
Se os vingadores vierem, quem são os
vingadores? É aqueles que conduzem a
nossa a direção da nossa mente de acordo
com o karma. E eles estão atrás também
nos apoiando com as visões que aparecem.
E você não conseguir evitar medit sobre
a raia grila.
Então essa é uma instrução super
importante, né? Assim, medit sua raia
griva. A raia griva é aquele que entra
no corpo do rudre e relincha dentro. Ou
seja, todas as as sensações internas que
a pessoa tenha, ela se tornam o alerta
para a clareza da mente. Isso é raia
gria.
Uma vez que agora você possui uma
percepção sobrenatural sutil, você terá
conhecimento sobre todos os lugares.
Por isso, faça uma escolha.
A seguir, a duas instruções,
uma sobre a transferência para um reino
búdico puro
e sobre escolher uma entrada do útero
impura do Sansara,
né? Nós ainda temos a chance agora de
projetar consciência em direção a uma
terra pura do Buda.
A transferência para o reino búdico do
espaço de faculdades purificadas
é dirigida dessa forma.
Ah, como é triste que eu ainda sigo
neste pântano, pântano lamacento do
Sansara.
Mesmo depois de tantas incontáveis eras
sem início e sem fim, enquanto todos
outros já se tornaram budas, eu ainda
não fui liberado.
Eu já vi os praticantes do CEP também
falarem coisas parecidas assim do tipo,
eu não tenho qualidade nenhuma. Eu vejo
que tem tutores, que tem gente que vai
lá, escuta, entende tudo. Eu não entendo
nada.
Eu não tenho solução.
Ah, como é triste que eu ainda sigo
nesse pântalo láento do Sansara, mesmo
depois de tantas incontáveis eras, sem
início e sem fim.
Então, eu já vi também mesmo as pessoas
que elas às vezes elas pensam que não
tem como progredir, tem um momento que
elas andam assim,
já vi pessoas dentro do CB assim muito
mal, pessoas agressivas, pessoas com uma
faca na mão
assim.
E eu mesmo depois de tantas incontáveis
eras sem início nem fim, enquanto tanto
tantos outros já se tornaram budas, eu
ainda não fui liberado.
Deste momento em diante passo a sentir a
náusea desse sansara.
Estou apavorado, cansado.
Agora cansado do quê? De ficar sempre
vagueando, procurando uma outra coisa,
inventando uma outra coisa.
Agora é hora de me preparar para
escapar. Então, preciso fazer surgir o
nascimento espontâneo na flor de Lotus
aos pés do Buda Amitaba, no reino
bem-aventurado
Sucavate
do Oeste.
[Risadas]
Com esse pensamento,
concentre-se intensamente no reino da
bem-aventurança oeste, fazer esse
esforço é vital ou então se direcionar
uma concentração intensa, unifocada e
sem distração a qualquer reino que
deseje, o reino puro, a completa alegria
ou densamente preenchido, ou o reino das
folhas de Salgueiro, ou da montanha da
palmeira,
O palácio da luz de Lotus em Oran.
Ah, você imediatamente,
esse Palácio da Luz de Lotos Georgia é o
alto paraíso, quer dizer, o paraíso mais
alto.
Você imediatamente nascerá naquele
reino. Aquele reino é assim, volta e
meia tem fogo que aparece assim por todo
lado.
É maravilhoso.
se desejar ir ao encontro da presença do
Senhor Maitreia, então tem o jardim de
Maitreia que é bem ali perto no Reino
Alegre.
Concentre-se
neste pensamento, neste ponto do estado
do Bardo. Chegou a hora de eu me juntar
à presença do Senhor Maitreia no reino
alegre. Assim irei. Você nascerá
espontaneamente no coração de um lotus
na presença de Maitreia.
Então, a pessoa ela é como se fosse a
prática de poa mesmo, né? A pessoa ela
concentra mente, p, ela visualiza,
como é que ela visualiza aquele reino?
Ela ela vê a perfeição
da terra pura a partir dos olhos da
deidade. Então, a pessoa assume os olhos
de sabedoria e aí a terra pura aparece,
né? É isso.
Ou então, se você não quiser fazer isso
e desejar entrar em um útero
ou achar que deve entrar em um, existe
uma instrução sobre como se escolher uma
entrada de útero de um reino impuro do
sansara.
Você procure uma namorada.
Não, não, essa parte aí não tem. Como
antes, olho para o continente
que você vai escolher como uma percepção
sobrenatural.
Ela não é algo natural, é uma
construção.
Ingresse em um local onde o dharma
floresce,
um lugar delusivo, onde tem um templo
delusivo, que todos sabem o que é um
templo delusivo. É assim. Aí é um local
onde o dharma floresce. Se estiver a
caminho de nascer em uma pilha de fees
imundas, bom, aí já não é interessante
na sua percepção. Essa massa fétida terá
um perfume doce e o atrairá. Ops. E você
nascerá ali. Assim o que quer que
apareça, não confie. Ponha fim a todos
os sinais de desejo e ódio e escolha
direito uma entrada do outro.
Novamente, é muito importante se
concentrar deste modo. Nascerei como um
inspirador universal para benefício de
todos os seres sencientes no signo de
Leão, pela dor universal. Fazer o que? É
pouca, não é pouca coisa, né? Ou como um
braana. Então é um aqui seria, enfim, um
piniano assim, né? ou como Bramana, tal
como uma grande árvore sala,
>> ou como o filho de um sida, ou em uma
família de linhagem pura do dharma, ou
em uma família onde o pai e a mãe
possuem fé. E ao assumir um corpo com
méritos, capaz de beneficiar todos os
seres sencientes,
produzirei o benefício.
Pá, aqui já tá super bom, né? Já
melhorou muito. Concentrando-se nesse
pensamento, o útero deve adentrar, deve
ser adentrado.
Nesta hora você deve abençoar o útero no
qual está ingressando. Então você olha
aquele lugar que você vê que aquele
lugar aparece, aí você abençoe
ao vê-lo como palácio de deuses. e vê-lo
como palácio de deuses. Suplicar a todos
os budas e bodisátuas das 10 direções
dos idans, sobretudo ao Senhor da grande
compaixão, e adentrar o útero aspirando
por uma solicitação de transmissão.
Então, a gente tá naquele local, por
exemplo, a nossa casa. Então, a gente
abençoa a nossa casa como um útero
dos budas.
É possível cometer erros ou escolher a
entrada de útero desse modo, ao
percebermos uma boa entrada de útero
como sendo ruim ou vice-versa sobre a
influência do karma. Portanto,
novamente,
o ponto essencial da instrução é muito
importante.
Faça isso.
Mesmo que a entrada do útero pareça boa,
não confie.
Mesmo que ela pareça ruim, não tem
aversão. O segredo verdadeiro e
profundo, essencial é adentrar o supremo
estado de equilíbrio, no qual não há
nada bom ou ruim, aceitação ou rejeição,
paixão ou agressão.
Então aqui isso significa o quê? Se a
pessoa tiver uma maturidade
no dharma,
ela imagina que o dharma consegue
transformar, seja qual for a situação,
em situação favorável.
Mas a exceção dos poucos que têm
experiência nisso, é difícil se livrar
da doença e das más tendências
inconsciente.
Assim, para evitar que a pessoa tome
refúgio entre transgressores
ou seres de capacidade, capacidades
muito pobres,
os inferiores, entre os inferiores como
os animais.
Se ela não for capaz de romper a paixão
e agressão, devemos chamar a pessoa
morta pelo seu nome outra vez e recitar
estas palavras.
Ó filho de nobre família, se não souber
como escolher uma entrada do útero e não
for capaz de se livrar da paixão e da
agressão,
quaisquer das experiências acimas que
surgirem,
chame o nome das três joias e tome
refúgio nelas.
Suplica ao Senhor da grande compaixão.
Sigue em frente com a cabeça erguida.
Abandone um apego e o anseio por
parentes e e amigos, filhos e filhas que
deixou para trás. Eles não podem o
ajudar. Adentre agora a luz azul do
reino humano ou a luz branca dos deuses
da forma e da não forma. Adentre os
palácios adornados com joias e os
jardins de prazeres.
Isso deve ser repetido até sete vezes.
Então, devemos suplicar aos budas e
bodsátuas e ler a prece. do bardo que
protege do medo. Os versos principais do
bardo e a liberação do perigoso caminho
do bardo até sete vezes. A seguir
devemos ler a liberação por meio do
vestir que libera os escândalas
espontaneamente.
também as práticas diárias que liberam
espontaneamente as tendências
inconscientes.
Devemos ler isso de modo claro e nítido.
Desse modo, ao atingir.
Desse modo, ao agir de forma apropriada,
os yogues de lucidez mais elevadas,
mais elevada realizam a ejeção da
consciência no bardo no momento antes da
morte e não precisam vaguear no estado
do bardo, contornando-o e atingindo a
liberação.
Aixo deles, algumas poucas pessoas
experientes reconhecem a luminosidade de
Darmata após o bardo do momento antes da
morte contornando-o
e se tornando Budas.
Abaixo delas são liberados,
aqueles abaixo delas são liberados de
acordo com seus resultados cármicos em
algum ponto nas semanas seguintes,
durante a manifestação dos budas
pacíficos e irados já no bardo de dar.
Visto que há muitos estágios eles
reconhecerão o que for apropriado e
atingirão a liberação.
Mas aqueles cujos bons resultados
cármicos são fracos
e que possuem muitos véus de engano e um
karma negativo pesado, acabarão por
vaguear em direção ao bardo do vira.
Contudo, visto que há muitas
demonstrações,
tal qual os degraus de uma escada, seja
muitas transmissões de clareza,
tal qual os degraus de uma escada, eles
reconhecerão em um ponto ou outro e
serão liberados.
Mas se estes, cujos bons resultados
cármicos são muito fracos, não
reconhecerem em nenhum desses momentos e
forem subjulgados pelo medo,
há uma série de instruções sobre como
fechar a entrada do útero e sobre como
escolher uma entrada
de útero.
Portanto, eles reconhecerão em uma ou em
outra, e, confiando no objeto de
meditação,
atingirão o mais elevado estado de
virtude
incomensurável.
Mesmo os mais inferiores, como os
animais,
dão as costas aos reinos inferiores por
meio da virtude de tomar refúgio. Eles
alcançarão alcançarão um corpo humano
precioso, pleno, com todas as liberdades
e boas oportunidades,
e na vida seguinte encontrarão um guru
sagrado, um amigo espiritual, de modo
que receberão a instrução e serão
liberados.
Se esse ensinamento for recebido no
bardo do vira,
a instrução prolongará os bons
resultados cármicos da pessoa. Como
instalar uma tubulação em um canal
hidráulico quebrado. Então essa é a
instrução, né? É como conectar um cano
de água quebrada.
Se esse ensinamento for recebido no
bardo do viraceiro, a instrução
prolongará os bons resultados cármicos
da pessoa, como instalar uma tubulação
em um canal hidráulico quebrado.
É impossível mesmo para os maiores dos
dos transgrressores
não atingir a liberação ao ouvir esse
ensinamento. E por quê? Porque durante o
bardo,
os convites compassivos de todos os
budas e deidades pacíficos e irados e o
convite dos tentadores e de forças
negativas se unirão.
Portanto,
ao simplesmente escutar o ensinamento,
nesta hora, a atitude das pessoas é
influenciada e elas atingem a liberação,
porque elas passam a ver as aparências
como
lucidez.
Uma vez que o corpo mental não possui
uma base de carne e osso, é fácil
exercer influência.
Independentemente de terem ido longe no
estado do Bardo, os seres vêm e ouvem
com sua percepção cármica sutil e
sobrenatural.
Isso é extremamente benéfico,
pois assim eles compreendem
e sua mente é instantaneamente
influenciada.
Isso é como o dispositivo de uma
catapulta ou como um tronco gigante que
não pode ser movido nem por 100 homens,
mas pode ser rapidamente
levado a qualquer lugar quando colocado
na água. É como controlar um cavalo com
as rédias.
Portanto, devemos nos conectar a todos
que morreram. E se o cadáver estiver
presente, o amigo deve ler esse lembrete
diversas vezes até que saia sangue e
pouso de suas narinas.
Enquanto isso, o cadáver não deve ser
perturbado.
As orientações são as seguintes:
Não se deve sacrificar animais em
dedicação à pessoa morta. Na presença do
corpo, parentes e amigos não devem
chorar ou se lamentar. ou ficar fazendo
barulho. Isso deve ser feito em outro
lugar e deve-se realizar tantos ato,
tantos atos de virtude quantos forem
possível.
Junto a esse ensinamento da grande
liberação pela escuta, é muito bom que
algum dos outros ensinamentos seja lido
após o fim dessa instrução.
Devemos ler este texto continuamente e
saber de cor o significado de suas
palavras e termos.
Assim, quando a morte se tornar certa
e os sinais de morte tiverem sido
reconhecidos,
se nossa condição permitir, devemos
lê-lo em voz alta e contemplá-lo.
Se não nos for possível fazer isso, deve
ser solicitado a um irmão ou irmã do
dharma que o faça, pois essa instrução
certamente conduzirá à liberação, sem
dúvida alguma.
Tal ensinamento não requer nenhuma
prática. É uma instrução profunda que
libera ao simplesmente ser vista, ouvida
e lida.
Então,
instrução profunda conduz os grandes
transgressores pelo caminho. Se não
esquecermos suas palavras e termos, nem
ao serem perseguidos por sete cachorros,
nem nem ao ser perseguido por sete
cachorros, a instrução liberará no bardo
do momento antes da morte.
Mesmo que todos os budas do passado,
presente e futuro procurassem, eles
nunca encontrariam ensinamento melhor do
que este.
A instrução do bardo que libera os seres
humanos,
a essência mais profunda e secreta, a
grande liberação pela escuta. Esse
tesouro foi descoberto pelo sida Carma
limpa na montanha de Gampodar.
que ela beneficie o dharma e todos os
seres sencientes.
Então, a gente terminou essa leitura e a
gente vai parar por aqui a a o nosso
estudo, né? Então você bem agora vou ver
o que que vai acontecer semana que vem,
que vai ser uma semana mais curta também
ainda.
>> É, eu já viajo logo em seguida.
Eu acho que eu chego aqui 27, né,
que é segunda-feira.
Aí 28 eu já viajo que é terça.
Então semana que vem a gente não vai
fazer nada. E aí eu volto dia 6.
com
se eu você ater
achei um pouco preconceituoso
traduzir s e siners como transgressão e
transgressores.
Pois-me, se eu andar sem capacete, eu
estou sendo transgressor, né? Mas isso
não é visto como um pecado, não é?
Então, pecado e pecadores é muito mais
Quem traduz é o trúng. Então, eu acho
que devia ser traduzido como pecado e
pecadores que tá no inglês, né? É a
palavra em português transgressão, em
inglês é parecido. Então, s é pecado.
Ah,
>> é diferente, né?
>> Mas eu acho que transgressor é melhor
que pecado, não é? pecadores.
>> É porque pecador, pecado não tem no
budismo de fato, assim, né?
>> Eu vejo assim como cristão,
né? Ou né, a nossa cultura cristã, né?
É, essa palavra existe e tem um sentido,
né?
E ela é mais eh potente do que
transgressão.
Assim,
>> mas eu acho que o sentido mais literal é
transgressão. O sentido mesmo assim
dentro do budismo seria transgressão e
não pecado.
>> Então e por que é que o o Lama acha que
o o o trunpa não pensou nisso? Porque
ele entendeu?
É
>> porque eu acho que a palavra
transgressor existe também no
>> Claro, transgresso é a mesma palavra.
>> É, mas talvez no inglês o pecador seja
um transgressor também. Não sei se é tão
é tão pesado como para nós assim, né?
Para nós
>> no inglês também ex igual
>> como
>> no inglês sim pecador, né? Pecado é
assim.
>> Eu acho que pecador significa a gente já
tá culpando, né?
é fazendo alguma coisa que não deve,
que é pior do que
>> tem um julgamento, tem uma clareza do
que eu deveria obedecer e tem alguma
coisa que eu não faço, mas o
transgressor é alguém que não que eu
usaria para para assim, ele tá preso à
ignorância, é uma coisa assim, mas
aquele que tá preso à ignorância, será
que eu chamo ele de pecador?
Eu acho que pecador é alguma coisa que
intensifica o sentido de identidade
dele.
Porque aí eu, bom, ele é um pecador. Tem
algumas pessoas que elas também se
julgam pecadores, aí elas constróem uma
identidade aflitiva, negativa, né?
palavras de inglês elas são parecidas,
mas na cultura é um pouco diferente.
E como é falso cognato que chama, né?
>> É falso cognato é literalmente o
sentido.
>> Ah, tá.
>> Às vezes o sentido se mantém, mas
>> se usam de um outro jeito, né? tom
diferente.
>> Nesse caso, eu não sei também não sei.
>> Também percebi que que não foi a pessoa
que
>> humar
queumado.
>> Hum.
>> Mas acho que foi tudo a Carolzinha. Eu
acho que a Carola,
mas talvez ela não tenha tido esse olhar
de de revisar, né? Não deu tempo.
>> Uhum.
[Música]
Uhum.
Talvez alguma coisa interessante que
disseram que pecado originalmente essa
palavra era um nome que se dava a
distância entre o centro e o lugar onde
se tira a flecha e onde a flecha batia.
Então a distância do centro é o pecado.
>> Hum.
>> Aí um tempo a igreja foi evoluindo, né?
A vida não é fácil.
Pode falar, Marta, por favor.
liberou agora,
>> tá?
>> Bom dia, Lama. Bom dia, Sangata,
gratidão.
>> Bom dia.
>> Bom dia, Lama. Eh, duas coisas, uma é
bem bem prática. Eh, nós vamos voltar ao
estudo das daquines no futuro. Aí
>> a gente não terminou, né?
Não,
>> não, a gente vai seguir sim,
>> vai
>> não.
>> Então, então tá. Eh, durante todo o
estudo, agora vindo especificamente pro
estudo, durante todo o estudo, a gente
viu muito de uma maneira muito eh
incisiva assim no no na na
principalmente no início, né? A questão
da não existência do tempo. Não existe o
tempo.
>> Uhum. Certo?
>> Mas no entanto, as coisas acontecem numa
sequência.
Existe um antes e um depois.
>> Uhum.
>> E como é que fica? Como é que a gente
Então isso não significa passagem de
tempo, já que é uma fase, depois outra
fase. Se existe uma sequência, se existe
um antes e um depois, não existe tempo.
>> É, com certeza. Mas é que esse aspecto
de antes e depois ele se dá dentro da
perspectiva convencional, né?
Ou o próprio caminho se dá dentro do
mundo convencional. Aí aí surge essa
sensação delusiva de tempo, né?
E aí quando a gente fala nos 49 dias,
>> ah, tudo isso é dentro do mundo
delusivo.
>> Quem tá lá mesmo não tem essa, esse
tempo não existe.
>> É
>> certo. Gratidão.
Bom dia, Norine.
>> Bom dia, Lama.
O, teve um pedaço lá do do texto, Lama,
que foi falado na meditação sobre a
luminosidade,
eh, a partir de todos os elementos. Que
meditação, que forma é essa?
Os elementos eles, por exemplo, quando a
gente a gente diz, "Bom, hoje é uma
sexta-feira,
hoje é uma quinta, né? Hoje é uma
quarta, sim, amanhã quinta, hoje é uma
quarta-feira. Então isso já seria o
elemento terra
amanhã, então tal coisa.
Então esse estabelecimento delusivo, né,
ele é terra. a gente pode dizer, bom,
hoje a gente concluiu o estudo do livro
Tibetano dos Mortos, né? Isso é um é uma
construção de um elemento terra.
>> Uhum.
>> A natureza da nossa mente, ela é livre
de qualquer referência desse tipo, né?
Assim.
>> Uhum. Então, a grande abertura, ela não
tem propriamente tempo,
mas os mundos, as bolhas, elas surgem
com uma constru com as construções e aí
são sequenciais, a gente tem tempo
surgindo.
>> Uhum. Tá. E só mais uma coisinha, Lana,
quando falou ali na liberação de vestir
que libera os escândalos,
>> isso é uma
tem um pé de página que explica essa
liberação pelo v
>> que é um texto que a pessoa
ela coloca no peito junto do corpo.
>> Hum. Tá, eu vejo depois. Obrigada. Tá
bem.
Hum.
>> É,
>> é.
Aqui eu tô indo pro reino de Amitaba. Aí
tudo bem, né? Terrapola de Amitaba,
por favor.
Pra gente poder transformar tudo isso já
no aspecto prático do nosso dia a dia,
seria correto eu pensar que, bom, tá
terminando o ensinamento, daqui a pouco
eu vou almoçar. Isso já há uma
visualização de entrada no útero. Eu tô
pensando, por exemplo, o lugar que eu
vou, o que eu vou comer, o que vai ser à
tarde.
>> Pode ser pensado assim. Seria a
instrução do que o Trumpa tá trazendo a
gente já nesse momento começar a olhar
isso como a própria deidade em vez de
manter uma visualização de terra?
>> Pode ser, pode ser
>> porque inevitavelmente vai ter que
almoçar, mas eu entendo que isso é mais
uma condição humana que o caro humano
tenho que almoçar, mas
>> pode pensar sim, com certeza.
>> Constância, por favor.
Bom dia, Lama. Bom dia.
>> Gratidão, Lama, pelos ensinamentos. Eh,
desesperada, Lama, mas não vou dar
conta, não vai dar certo.
>> Mas sempre dá certo. A pessoa no fim, no
fim, aquilo é difícil, difícil, mas a
pessoa morre.
>> Sempre dá certo. Eu só relaxar assim que
pá, a gente vai.
>> Então, Lama, e aí o que eu o que eu vim
fazer e perguntar pro Lama é assim, ó.
Eh, há alguma prática, eh, de tipo
assim, porque tá, eu vou morrer e aí tem
todas essas instruções. Talvez ali nos
primeiros, eu ainda por ter ainda uma
ligação com com o meu corpo, eu ainda vá
lembrar dos ensinamentos do que o Lama
falou, porque eu vou chamar o Lama. fica
atento que eu vou est chamando lama, vou
est chamando,
>> se eu não tiver ocupado,
>> então assim, pode ser que ali eu vou est
ali naquele momento, mas chega um ponto
onde aquilo se desfaz. Então assim, eh,
o que eu vou estar comigo é o que é
muito interno mesmo assim, é aquilo que
que ficou impregnado na minha essência.
>> É isso que eu vou conseguir segurar. É,
>> então, e o a minha pergunta é como eu eh
enraizar isso na na minha essência, algo
que vai me ajudar nesse processo do tipo
assim para eu não sair correndo, me
enfiar no buraco, sabe?
Eu acho que durante a vida tu vai
praticando, vai olhando assim o tempo
todo né?
Vai recitando prágina paramita forma,
sensação, percepção, formação mental,
consciência. Todo buraco vai surgir como
forma sensação percepção formação
mental, consciência. Aí tu vai olhando,
apareceu o buraco, tu forma, sensação,
percepção, formação mental, conceção,
vacuidade. Diz da vacuidade eles brotam.
Aí tu fica olhando todas essas essas
aparências desse modo. Aí tu vai
purificando isso, fazer as oferendas.
só fazendo as oferendas constantemente
para o Buda primordial, para sata, para
para
>> certo? Porque um dos ensinamentos que me
toca mais profundamente desde que eu
comecei a caminhar dentro do budismo é a
prátina para mí, assim, né? No meu dia a
dia, eu sempre tô olhando aquilo
vazio, assim. Então essa é uma forma de
eu enraizar esse isso dentro do meu da
minha essência.
>> Certeza. Super bom.
>> Obrigada.
Se quiser retornar essa linguagem aqui,
como a gente estava estudando, entra na
grande confissão, a confissão suprema.
Aí aquilo eu tenho a explicação toda
ali.
Tenta entender linha por linha aquilo.
Tá tudo ali.
>> Muito obrigada de coração.
>> Bom constância. ou pega o próprio texto
esse e olha de novo. De novo, aí vai
entendendo certeza.
>> Gratidão.
>> Rúbia,
>> bom dia, Lana.
Bom dia.
Eh,
eu tava ontem olhando que ele tem uma um
ele dá um salto entre o bardo
da morte e o bardo do pós-me. Depois ele
dá um outro salto do bardo do pós-mardo
do vira,
né? que tem uma hora que ele diz assim
que o corpo do do a forma do corpo
anterior já não existe e a forma da vida
futura ainda vai ser plasmada. Então
eles tem esse momento assim que é como
se fosse um
>> Sim.
>> salto quântico.
>> É,
>> né, filha? Aí eu fiquei pensando que eu
queria que o senhor falasse um pouco
sobre a estética, que o senhor sempre
vem falando essa palavra da estética.
Então, por exemplo, eh, a gente foi aí
até Viamão, tinha um professor
convidado. Aí o professor convidado
tinha uma estética que
é de roupa branca,
não corta o cabelo.
Aí tem aquela prática assim assim assado
que é do método daquela estética.
Então, quando o professor foi, que o
senhor voltou,
disse: "É de roupa preta, cabeça
raspada, vocês viram pra parede
que tem a palmatória do professor."
Então eu fiquei pensando que tem o Idan
que é
só sambogakia e tem o professor que é de
verdade
>> isso. Porque mesmo que eu compreenda a
estética do professor visitante,
ainda assim ele vai embora e eu fico
aqui com esse ensinamento. Então, no Zem
tem uma estética que vai por esse, é
diferente da estética do Vajana, se a
gente podia em algum momento contemplar,
porque quando eu olhei para esse
pensamento, que eu olhei para quem olha
para esse pensamento, eu fiquei pensando
no porque ele fala às vezes o ele junta
o tempo e o ser.
Então, às vezes o ser aparece de uma
forma, às vezes aparece de outra e ele
não explica o salto quântico, nem
>> guruê também não explica.
>> Sim,
é sempre a não dualidade, né? Quando tu
escolhe eh um tipo de descrição, escolhe
um mundo, tá dentro de um mundo. Aí tu
olha a não dualidade e explica com as
palavras daquele mundo. Isso tá no outro
mundo. Tu vê a não dualidade, explica
com as palavras do outro mundo. Aí
quando tu sai de um mundo pro outro
parece que deu um salto quântico, mas tá
sempre com a mesmo tipo de experiência
no sentido sutil, secreto, né? Assim.
Então, as palavras às vezes mudam, mas é
são é a forma de explicar isso, né?
Se a gente tá indo nesse caminho de
estudando, se a gente poderia em algum
momento então estudar pelo ponto de
vista do zem
os texos,
>> eu acho, com certeza.
>> Era isso que eu queria pedir,
>> tá?
se a gente pode ir na em algum momento,
conforme a gente tá indo, se a gente
pode entrar nos textos do mestre Dougan.
Eu eu acho que essa pode ser uma boa
ideia, mas os textos do mestre Dog, eles
eles são coãs,
então,
ah, eu acho que cada um podia
experimentar. Eles estão disponíveis.
foram traduzid traduzidos pelo caso
sensei,
c sensei que teve aqui entre nós, né? Eu
acho bem interessante assim que isso
seja trabalhado, né? Mas os os textos do
Zen é como se eles não fossem para ser
explicados,
eles são para serem
meditados né?
como coisas que eh que a gente vai
entender, mas o ponto mesmo não é
entender
contemplar aquela dúvida mesmo, né?
Mas eventualmente a gente pode também
trabalhar alguns textos desse, com
certeza.
Mas principalmente a estética, assim, o
que que o laman quer dizer quando o lama
diz a estética
assim, porque a estética quando a gente
vira pra parede
é uma estética diferente de quando o
professor vê o xirinxirra na parede.
Ah, por exemplo, quando, eh, nós estamos
trabalhando
no texto da iluminação da sabedoria
primordial, aquele texto ele ele pode de
fato
ah ser comparado com a própria meditação
do zenho. Mas a gente tem feito um pouco
isso, né? Por exemplo, a gente divide em
chamata e visão. Aí o os azen já tem
chamata e visão juntos.
Então tem as
eh eu já tenho feito essas
ah
essas descrições, né?
É assim.
Agora, por exemplo, tem esse texto que é
o, né? Aí o velho mestre falou: "O ser
tempo se ergue dos mais altos picos das
montanhas.
O ser tempo se move no mais profundo
leito dos oceanos.
O ser tempo tem três cabeças e oito
braços.
O sertura de 8 ou 16 pés.
O ser tempo é um bastão de mestre.
O sert é um pilar ou uma lanterna de
pedra.
O seu tempo é José ou João, multou eu. O
seu tempo é a grande terra e os céus
acima.
Ser tempo significa tempo. Sendo tempo,
é existência.
E ser é totalmente tempo.
A forma de uma estátua dourada do Buda
com 16 pés de altura é tempo, porque ela
é tempo. Ela tem a gloriosa radiância
dourada do tempo. Isso é uma outra
estática.
Se tu quiser, eu mando esse texto para
ti. Muito lindo contemplar isso.
Tem a tradução do caso sensei também
desse texto.
É assim.
Aí fica essa questão. E eu sei ser tempo
seria o quê? Então o que que é isso que
ele quer dizer, né? É assim. Então isso
é uma autoestética.
Aqui no budo tibetano, nós estamos
apontando diretamente a natureza última,
apontando aquilo, né? instruindo como
faz para sentar e ver aquilo
assim
no Zenhas te convido assim quando tu
tiver sentado meditando, como que tu
pode estar separado da natureza última?
Como que tu pode estar separado? Então,
por que apontar?
Tu tá ali.
Agora, muitas pessoas, mesmo que receba
essa instrução, elas talvez não consigam
reconhecer a natureza última.
Aí elas perguntam: "E como é que é isso
que a gente não vê?" Aí eles respondem:
"Pratique".
Tá? Então tá.
Essa é uma estética que não tem muitas
palavras, né? E é como se o caminho
dessa estética ele não fosse
propriamente
o caminho do estudo, mas ele fosse o
caminho da meditação mesmo, né?
Assim.
E a e a palmatória aparece em que
momento?
>> É quando a pessoa tá meditando e ela tem
muito, muito sofrimento em meio à
meditação e o tempo não passa e a mente
da pessoa flutua, então ela tem aquilo
que é chamado espada de mandere, né?
É tipo quando sai da primeira semana pra
segunda que ele escorrega no poste.
No no zen não tem propriamente essa
estética também do poste, porque não tem
o colocar a pessoa num lugar,
>> tem a pessoa senta diante de uma parede,
ela já tá o poste inteiro, pessoa já
sumiu ali, ela não pratica noutro lugar
a não ser no topo do poste, não tem como
se como abandonar o topo do poste,
porque a natureza búdica já tá na
pessoa.
Aí a pessoa não tem essa experiência,
ela pensa que tem, mas talvez não tenha,
né? E aí esse encontro é a própria
estética da prática.
Seria assim, a gente pratica um dia, no
outro dia pratica de novo, depois
pratica de novo e não pede instrução
porque tudo já tá ali,
como se entre uma linha e a outra
tivesse 49 dias ou um instante assim.
Ele tá tipo descrevendo entre uma linha
e outra, os bardos, não sei quê, toda
essa coisa que a gente ouviu é como se
fosse entre um ud e o outro.
Por um tempo o ser tá num lugar, por
outro tempo tá no outro. Às vezes ele
vai fazer uma transição, porque ele
falou assim, ah, lembrei, ele falou
assim: "Você pode tomar essa instrução
como sendo uma instrução instantânea ou
como sendo uma instrução gradual".
depende de você.
>> É,
>> então como se fosse instantâneo isso.
Ele tá agarrado já no no alto do poste
sempre é instantâneo.
>> É instrução,
>> né? Essa instrução,
ela vem assim, a pessoa pode atingir
liberação em muitos diferentes momentos.
Então, uma instrução de terenzig, ele tá
ali, ele tá olhando aonde que a pessoa
tá, ele tenta estabelecer uma linguagem
e apontar o aspecto último. Aí não deu
daquele modo, ele tenta um outro jeito.
Ele vai olhando sempre, sempre
procurando aonde tem méritos. Ele produz
uma
instrução que pode liberar a pessoa
daquilo.
Aí no fim a pessoa não atinge liberação.
Ele ajuda a pessoa a renascer numa
condição mais favorável, não numa
condição pior.
Ele dá instruções de como durante a vida
a gente pode ir recitando para favorecer
esse momento ou esses momentos onde nós
vamos
vaguear sem coragem de olhos, ouvidos,
nariz, língua e tato.
Essas instruções elas não têm no zenha.
A instrução seria sempre a mesma. Quando
você morreu, você repousa sobre diante
da parede, que é uma das instruções que
tem aí dentro.
Aí você simplesmente repousa em uma
mudra na grande no grande selo. Sempre
que vocês ouvirem grande selo, isso pode
ser interpretado como o próprio zem.
Grande selos. Repouso,
simplesmente repouso nessa grande
abertura.
Mahamramudra é como se fosse o Z.
Entendi agora.
>> Ai, obrigado.
>> Tá bem,
obrigada.
Olivia Sanga. O alivia vai perguntar
primeiro.
>> Acho que dele
[Música]
>> eh, duas perguntinhas. A a primeira,
>> por favor,
>> como
>> por favor, Olivia, por favor. Alegria te
ver aí.
>> Eh,
eu acho que foi uns dois dias atrás eh
que você falou sobre mantras, né?
sobre
>> sobre mantras e sobre a fala,
eh, a f mais e conceptual. Eu tava me
perguntando, eu uma, na verdade, uma
coisa que eu sinto, mas talvez eh não tô
no caminho certo. Eh, o mantra muitas
vezes não é uma frase assim e que tem
uma construção,
vamos dizer intelectual.
>> O mantra
>> é são são é um conjunto,
>> isso com certeza
>> um conjunto de cíl representa
uma vibração, que são uma vibração, tá
bom?
>> Com certeza. Eh, seria correto de pensar
que eles são eh, na verdade o ferramenta
para ir além eh de qualquer
intelectualização ou conceitualização.
Ah, é isso mesmo.
Eh, minha segunda pergunta é sobre eu
tava ouvindo a alguns dias atrás
as 21 instruções vitais eh da prática do
Panamba pro Dunch.
E aí eu me perguntei se eh a sabedoria e
a compaixão são dois ferramentas. Uma
vez que na na Clara Luz,
como que fica esse esse esses esses
ferramentas se desolvam também na Clara
Luz?
Ah, não, elas são um aspecto luminoso,
elas são uma manifestação,
elas são uma apresentação da grande
abertura.
Porque quando eu tô aqui falando de
clara luz, eu falo de vacuidade também,
né? Então, essas manifestações são
manifestações luminosas, inseparáveis da
vacuidade.
Então, as próprias deidades elas vão
surgir como uma expressão compassiva. As
deidades elas surgem
e
a função delas é manifestar uma forma
que ajuda a conexão
das pessoas com as suas estruturas
cármicas, mas as deidades elas apontam
essas estruturas cármicas e elas
iluminam essas estruturas cármicas se
dissolvendo novamente na vacuidade, né?
Então esse é o processo. As deidades
elas são o as fixações que nós temos,
elas vão surgindo como deidades.
Então assim, sabedoria, a compaixão é
uma coisa que e eh presente o tempo
todo. Elas não separam. Sabedoria e
compaixão tão juntas, porque a compaixão
de fato é a superação da ignorância de
aí, que nós podemos ajudar os seres com
compaixão, mas se a gente não liberá-los
de aídia, aí não tem solução. E a vídea
é a perda da lucidez. Então, a sabedoria
ela tá junto com a superação da
ignorância. E ela é a própria sabedoria,
é o próprio instrumento,
é o próprio instrumento da compaixão,
né? Sabedoria é a própria compaixão,
porque ela dissolve a raiz de todo
sofrimento que é a ignorância.
Então, ela tá intrínseca. Quando nós
temos dharmmaca, darmacaia grande
abertura. Quando nós nos defrontamos com
as aparências, as aparências podem
surgir como sabedoria. Então, nesse
momento, surge a manifestação
sambogakaia.
Manifestação sambogakaia, elas são as
deidades e a lucidez das visões
correspondentes que conduzem a
darmacaia.
Os budas quando surgem num corpo físico,
eles surgem expressando tanto darmacaia
quanto as sabedorias sambogakaia.
Aí diferentes mundos tem diferentes
sabedorias sambogakia. Por isso que em
diferentes mundos os budas são
diferentes.
Os budistos que acompanham esses budas,
eles também são diferentes em cada
mundo.
>> Obrigado.
>> Tudo bem,
>> eu posso perguntar também,
>> por favor?
Eh, com relação
me dá a sensação assim dos dos
pensamentos e das emoções assim que
surge ouvindo esses ensinamentos.
Eh,
eu eu sei assim que tanto os pensamentos
como as emoções são como as ondas no
oceano, né, ou como as nuvens e que
>> a gente não vai ah se apegar a eles.
Quando a gente se identifica, a gente se
sente como a onda, né, ou como a nuv.
>> Sim. Mas ao mesmo tempo, assim, me
parece que é tão importante a gente
ah que pensamentos que nós estamos
construindo,
que isso vai determinar
ah
os mundos onde a gente tá se
manifestando assim.
>> Com certeza.
É isso mesmo.
Ou seja, os pensamentos
determinam os mundos onde nós estamos
automaticamente renascendo, né? É os
pensamentos e as visões, mais do que os
pensamentos, né? Porque as os
pensamentos eles estão associados a
visões.
As visões estão associadas aos
elementos. Então, quando eu começo a
olhar, eu vejo coisas fixas, coisas
móveis, vejo energia para movimentar
aquilo, aí nesse momento, eu já tô vendo
os mundos. Os mundos ficaram claros para
mim, como por exemplo, um jogo que eu
vou jogar, aquele mundo do jogo ficou
claro e eu sou o personagem que tô
movimentando aquilo tudo, né? Então
assim, os mundos surgem
e o pensamento ele vai surgir dentro
desses mundos já criados. Então a mente
ela tem duas áreas de ação muito claras.
Uma que é como que eu conecto uma coisa
com outra, que é a consciência. É o
terceiro dos 12 alos virginana. E existe
a luminosidade da mente que tá antes,
que ela já tá no primeiro dos 12 elas,
quando os mundos começam a aparecer.
Então, o pensamento sobre as coisas
começa depois de eu dizer: "Isso aqui é
uma torre, isso aqui é um bispo, isso
aqui é um jogo, eu tô um jogador". Aí
surge os pensamentos sobre aquilo.
Então, os pensamentos são uma parte
dentro disso, mas eles até não são a
parte principal.
Mas quando os pensamentos existem, eu
preciso entender que eu tô pensando
sobre coisas que são surgidas
luminosamente. Então, a ação da mente
que constrói aqueles aspectos luminosos,
ela já se exerceu, já aconteceu e ela
constitui os mundos como eu vejo.
que a gente para construir as visões, a
gente se utiliza da linguagem, né? Não,
>> isso já seria um período posterior que
tá um pouco associado aos pensamentos.
Então, por exemplo, quando eu vejo,
quando eu visualizo uma deidade ou uma
cor,
eu não uso linguagem.
É um aspecto luminoso direto. Uhum.
>> Quando eu troco uma cor por outra, uma
forma por outra, eu não preciso primeiro
produzir palavras para depois isso
acontecer.
>> Obrigada.
>> Tá bem.
Beijo aí,
pessoal. Eu tô vendo várias mãozinhas
aí, mas eu tenho que chegar 20 paraas 20
para uma na escola da Taliteta.
Então eu já tô atrasado
dentro do tempo que não existe.
>> Ama, só para saber se a prece é da
grande a prece grande da grande
liberação pela escuta é o que a Norine
falou.
[Música]
É, já não sei
se é o que a Norine falou.
>> Essa prece nós temos.
>> É ela, né? É,
>> a gente estudou.
>> É, a é o próprio texto, né?
>> Aham.
Tá. Grande,
>> tá bem, querido. Um beijo grande aí.
Tudo de bom.
>> Vamos. Queria fazer uma pergunta.
>> De repente
>> é rápido, prometo.
>> É assim, eu queria saber se o
se essa eh esse estudo ele se refere
somente à morte dos seres sencientes ou
à morte de todas as coisas?
>> Ah, essa é uma pergunta interessante. Eu
diria que se refere à morte de todas as
coisas.
Porém, eh, não sendo os seres sencientes
e os seres humanos,
é muito difícil que essas palavras sejam
compreendidas por eles.
Mas o sentido sutil de tudo que acontece
se refere a todos os a toda a vida.
E toda a vida ela tem a mesma natureza
que é a natureza luminosa e vazia que
sustenta todas as existências, né?
Então seria
eh você com relação à morte de uma bolha
ou morte de um objeto
seria com relação a mim e não a um
fluxo.
>> Os objetos eles a gente não considera
que eles sejam existências búdicas
porque é como se os objetos não eles
mesmos não tivessem uma capacidade de
manifestar o aspecto luminoso.
Os objetos é como se fossem criações
inanimadas,
delusivas das mentes que os vêm.
Bem,
beijo aí para todo mundo. Beijo aí,
Sara.
Tudo de bom, pessoal.
Lama gratidão.
Tchau, gente. Bom dia para todos.
Tá.